I want to follow up the last
video on the Sn2 ring opening
of the cyclohexene oxide.
Because the way I explained
it, it might have been a
little non-intuitive.
Because when we first learned
about Sn2 and Sn1 reactions,
we said, well if you have an
aprotic solvent with an OK
leaving group, but a really good
nucleophile, you'll have
an Sn2 reaction.
But if you have a protic solvent
with an excellent
leaving group and a weak
nucelophile, then that would
lead you to an Sn1 reaction.
All of the ingredients that I
showed you in the last video
actually were more in
this direction.
This was actually an acid
catalyzed reaction, so it was
definitely protic.
And then this ring is
strained right here.
This epoxide ring.
And we already protonated this
oxygen, so it was a good
leaving group.
And clearly, the water, the
H2O right here, is a weak
nucleophile.
So if we just went off of the
checklist that we learned
about when we just explored the
differences between Sn1
and Sn2 reactions, we probably
would have predicted an Sn1
reaction here.
We probably would have said the
first step would have been
that this bond just broke on
its own, and this guy just
left, forming a carbocation.
And only then would the water,
the weak nucleophile, would
have attacked the carbon.
In that case, it could have
attacked from either side.
Because all of a sudden it would
lose its handedness,
this carbon right here.
But everything I've read-- and
I've actually never performed
this reaction in the
chemistry lab.
But everything I've read
says that this is the
reaction that occurs.
That you actually have this,
I guess you could call it
stereospecificity.
The trans version is actually
what predominates.
And actually what is
going on is an Sn2.
So my best explanation is that
this is really more of, you
could call it an Sn2
like reaction.
Because it really meets the
checklist more for an Sn1 in
terms of what the
reactions are.
But because the end product
is actually selective, you
actually end up with the trans,
as opposed to both the
cis and the trans.
We're assuming that an Sn2 type
reaction must have occurred.
But I really wanted to
make this clear.
Because it really kind of goes
against the grain of our
checklist of predicting whether
an Sn1 or an Sn2
reaction would occur.
The reason why, at least in my
mind, I think that the Sn1
reaction maybe didn't occur is,
in order for it to occur,
this carbocation
needs to form.
And that carbocation
is secondary.
It's not tertiary.
So it's maybe just not
quite stable enough.
Now Sn1 reactions can
occur with epoxides.
I'll show you two examples.
So if I have-- let me draw
two examples here.
So this is ethane.
If I just did a double bond
here, it would be ethene.
But if I have these bonded
to an oxygen,
this is ethylene oxide.
And once again, if this was an
alkene, it would be called
either ethene-- that's actually
the official name,
but some people call
it ethylene.
And so the common name
for this is ethylene.
Actually I spelled it wrong.
It's ethylene, not with
the-- ethylene oxide.
I've even seen on the web a
couple of times, people call
this ethene oxide.
Which, in some ways, would
be more consistent.
Let's say on one hand, we have
ethene oxide, and let's say on
the other hand, we
have something
that looks like this.
Let me try my best to draw it.
We have something that
looks like this.
And so this part, if we just
look at the main chain.
You could either view
this as a propane.
Or having three carbons.
1, 2, 3.
And then a methyl breaking
off of it.
But this y shape, where you
have four carbons here, is
usually called isobutyl.
So you could call this
isobutylene oxide.
So let's call this isobutylene
oxide.
That's what you're more
likely to see.
Isobutylene oxide.
And remember, they
just pretend like
this is a double bond.
That's where we get the
isobutylene oxide.
But then to make it clear that
it's really not a double bond,
that there's really an oxygen
in there, it's really not an
alkene, you put the
oxide there.
Now let's think about the
different reactions that might
occur if we have a nucleophile
in either situation.
So if we have a nucleophile
over here for the ethylene
oxide, either of these carbons
are primary carbons.
So if you have a carbon
right here.
Let me draw all of its bonds.
It's bonded to one
other carbon.
It's bonded to a hydrogen, and
another hydrogen right there.
So it's a primary carbon.
It would not be a stable
carbocation.
So in this case, you would
definitely predict that an Sn2
reaction would have to occur
with this epoxide.
That the nucleophile would
attack back here.
And then this electron would be
taken back by the oxygen.
And that would open the ring.
So this would be an
Sn2 situation.
And in my mind, this
is pretty clear.
But in this situation,
you do have a primary
carbon right here.
It's only bonded to
one other carbon.
But over here, you have
a tertiary carbon.
It's bonded to 1,
2, 3 carbons.
So this would be a stable
carbocation.
So in this circumstance, you
would actually expect that
this epoxide ring is so
strained, that the first step
is that the oxygen would
just take the electron.
The oxygen would just
take the electron.
And then you're left
with something
that looks like this.
Let me do it in the same
colors, so it's clear.
You would be left
with something
that looks like this.
And now, since it took the
electron, just like that.
Or actually, maybe let
me take a step back.
It has to be very good
leaving group.
It wouldn't necessarily just
take the electron right there.
The first step in order to make
this a good leaving group
would be if you maybe had a
water around, or something
that it could take, or some type
of acid, that it could
take a hydrogen proton from.
So the first step is it would
take a hydrogen proton.
Let me do this a little
bit neater.
It would take a hydrogen
proton.
So it would give an electron to
a hydrogen proton, so that
it becomes a good
leaving group.
So now our molecule
looks like this.
Do it in the same colors.
Our molecule will
look like that.
That's our carbon.
And now this is an oxygen
bonded to a hydrogen.
And now this has a
positive charge.
This now will just be a water.
I won't draw it anymore.
And now this is an excellent
leaving group.
Tertiary carbon.
This is classic Sn1.
Classic Sn1 reaction.
So this guy can essentially
leave. And then we are left
with down here-- let me
draw it over here.
We're left with something that
will look like this.
We have our carbon
bonded, not to
hydrogens, to other carbons.
So these are carbons
over here.
And then this carbon is
bonded to this OH.
We now have an alcohol.
And this is now a carbocation.
And now this is ready to be
attacked by even a weak
nucleophile.
Even a weak nucleophile
could attack this.
So when you have a tertiary
carbon in your epoxide ring,
look for an Sn1 reaction.
But if you have anything less,
as far as I can tell, based on
the reactions that I've looked
at in multiple books-- if you
have secondary or primary
carbons, it seems like Sn2 is
going to be more likely to
break your epoxide ring.